there are two fundamentally different
ways to create and store images and this
affects how you deploy images
responsively raster and vector raster
images photographs and other images
represented as a grid of individual dots
of color raster images might come from a
camera or a scanner or be created with
the HTML canvas element vector images
images such as logos and line art which
can be defined as a set of curves lines
shapes fill colors and gradients vector
images can be created with programs like
Adobe Illustrator or Inkscape or from
using a vector format such as SVG SVG
makes it possible to include responsive
vector graphics in a webpage and we'll
talk more about this format later the
advantage of vector file formats over
raster file formats is that the browser
can render a vector image at any size
after all vector formats describe the
geometry of the image how it's
constructed from lines curves and colors
and so on not individual dots of color
let's see what happens when we resize
this page now that's an SVG image on the
right and a PNG on the left and you can
see as the size increases the PNG is
starting to look a little blurry whereas
the SVG is perfect at any size